so back in april of 2019 a man dropped
off an apparently water damage macbook
pro to delaware computer repair shop
outside wilmington a year later the new
york post reported on the contents of
that laptop but of course you know the
rest of the story big tech censored it
because we are on the eve of the
presidential election and hurt their
candidate whose campaign they were
funding joe biden and so they denounced
it including former heads of the intel
agencies as russian disinformation watch
disinformation that he knows to be
fabricated and supplied by a foreign
intelligence service and despite the
warning he's still doing it you have
said this entire thing is so obviously a
russian plot it's sort of
a crazy quilt at this point
which has all the hallmarks of russian
disinformation that said
it wasn't for lack of trying rudy
basically functioning as a russian asset
by pushing russian disinformation cnn
reported on friday that u.s authorities
are seeing if those emails we just
talked about are connected to an ongoing
russian disinformation effort
prediction the russia hysteria will not
age well we're going to look at this
tape in about 10 years and think what
country was that and it's kind of
starting to happen already they're now
admitting everyone's admitting the
laptop was not russian disinformation
it's real it was hunter biden's the
problem is that they smeared the repair
shop owner who had nothing to do with
any of this as a tool of putin
now that man is taking action his name
is john paul mack isaac he's the former
owner of the mac shop computer repair
store and he joins us tonight to explain
uh thanks so much for coming on this
week isaac appreciate it um so they
called you a tool of putin we know how
that feels what are you doing about it
well uh
i'm i'm taking them to court
it's the
the the collusion that took place on
in mid-october of 2020 just astonished
me when it happened and yes you know i
just couldn't i couldn't believe it it
was just a unilateral decision to all
call this russian disinformation without
even deciding if there was going to be
any collateral damage which there was
and you were that i mean i think the
country was hurt biden got elected in a
demonstrably unfair election but your
life was totally overturned tell us what
happened to you
well initially
uh people just assumed that i was a
hacker or a thief mainly because of
twitter labeling the material from the
laptop being hacked and then banning the
subject matter completely
but after
51 intelligence pillars of the
intelligence community decided to call
me a russian and disinformation campaign
and
and adam schiff went on cnn to follow
that up to express those concerns with
the rest of the nation uh it was pretty
much from that point on i was labeled
uh a stooge of putin and putin thanks
before his service
so you don't have your store anymore
no i i had to get out of town before the
election i had to close the shop and
leave delaware
yeah have you gotten a call from of
apology from adam schiff
no i don't expect to right now either
i i hope you see these creeps in a
bankruptcy i really mean that john paul
mcisaac an innocent bystander trying to
do the right thing
a tool of putin thank you for coming on
tonight i appreciate it
thanks for having me tucker thank you
very much
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight